♪
>> Tucker: IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA, THE
HOUSING CRISIS HAS BECOME SO
SEVERE THAT SOME HAVE
ADOPTED A NOVEL SOLUTION
THEY ARE LIVING ON BOATS AND
NOT QUAINT BOATS OFF SAUCE
IS
YACHTS.100 PEOPLE ARE LIVING ONR
YACHTS.100 PEOPLE ARE LIVING ONG
TAG FLOTILLA OF BARGES THE
PAPER DESCRIBES AS
DECREPTED.
SOME HOLD JOBS.
ONE WOMAN BOUGHT A BOAT FOR
15 GROUND BECAUSE RENT FOR
STUDIO APARTMENT HAD GROWN
TO $3,000 A MONTH.
DO THE MATH IT, WILL PAY FOR
ITSELF IN HALF LESS A YEAR.
MIGHT SOUND LIKE VENTURE
IT'S THIRD WORLD.
LIKE TENT CAMPS AREN'T
DESIGNED TO BE LIVED ON
PERMANENTLY.
DURING STORMS ENDANGERS
JERRY LIVES AND CAUSE HUGE
AMOUNTS OF DAMAGE.
THESE FLOTILLAS ARE ILLEGAL.
EXPLOITING HOUSING BAY AREA
DOESN'T SEEM INTERESTED IN
IT OR SERIOUS ABOUT FIXING
IT.
WHETHER IT'S SAN FRANCISCO
OR NEW YORK OR SEATTLE, WHEN
YOU THINK OF HOMELESSNESS
YOU THINK OF MAJOR CITIES.
THE HOMELESS CRISIS IS NOT
LIMITED TO BIG POPULATION
CENTERS.
SOME OF THE HARDEST HIT
PLACES ARE SMALL CITIES AND
TOWNS WHERE EVEN A SMALL
HOMELESS POPULATION CAN PUT
MASSIVE STRAIN ON PUBLIC
SERVICE.
FOR THE LATEST INSTALLMENT
IN OUR SERIES HOMELESS IN
AMERICA.
OUR PRODUCER WENT TO OREGON
WHERE ONE SMALL CHARITY IS
FIGHTING TO IMPROVE A
DESPERATE SITUATION IN
EUGENE.
WATCH.
OUR FIRST STOP IN PORTLAND,
OBAMACARE WASN'T MEANT TO BE
WORK RELATED FOR BREAKFAST
IN UPSCALE FASHIONABLE PEARL
DISTRICT.
WHEN WE ARRIVED WE FOUND A
HOMELESS MAN RIFLING THROUGH
A CRASH CAN IN THE PARKING
LOT A DIRTY SYRINGE.
HOMELESSNESS IN PORTLAND
LOOKS A LOT LIKE WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN IN OTHER CITIES.
LOTS OF TENTS, LOTS OF
DRUGS.
THE CITY'S PERMISSIVE
CULTURE TEMPERATE CLIMATE
AND GENEROUS SOCIAL SERVICES
ATTRACT I HAVE A GRANTS AND
ADDICTS FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
WE MET A WOMAN CALLED
LIBERTY HOPE OFF CLOVERLEAF
SHE SAYS SHE CAME TO THE
WEST COAST BECAUSE SHE
NEEDED MEDICAL TREATMENT FOR
HER LEUKEMIA.
SHE MOVED TO PORTLAND AFTER
POLICE TOWED HER MOTOR HOME.
>> THEY TOWED MY MOTOR HOME.
GOT OUT NOWHERE TO GO.
BUT I COULDN'T LEAVE BECAUSE
I STILL HAD TREATMENTS I HAD
TO DO.
>> Tucker: HOPE SAYS SHE IS
BLESSED BECAUSE THE CITY
SHUTTLES HER BETWEEN MEDICAL
CLINIC AND HER TENT.
SHE HOPES TO GET BACK TO
HOME STATE OF MONTANA ONCE
SHE IS HEALTHY AGAIN.
>> HOW LONG DO YOU THINK YOU
WILL BE HERE.
>> I'M NOT TOO SURE.
I BROKE MY FOOT THIS PAST
WINTER SO IT KIND OF SET ME
BACK.
WITH MY MEDICAL.
BUT I'M A MIRACLE SO EVERY
DAY IS A MIRACLE.
>> Tucker: SIMILAR TENT
ENCAMPMENTS LINE PORTLAND'S
IOWAS EVERY OPEN FACE IN THE
CITY SEEMS PACKED WITH
PEOPLE LIVING OUTSIDE AND
USING DRUGS.
RIVER FRONT PARK DOWNTOWN
RECEPTACLE FOR USED HEROIN
SYRINGES.
OREGON IS A SMALL STATE BUT
HOMELESS PEOPLE MORE PER
CAPITA THAN NEIGHBORING
WASHINGTON OR CALIFORNIA.
TO GET A SENSE OF THE SCALE
OF THE PROBLEM, WE DROVE TO
EUGENE IN THE CENTRAL PART
OF THE STATE.
EUGENE IS A COLLEGE WITH A
POLITICS TO MATCH.
NOT SURPRISINGLY IT HAS
ENORMOUS HOMELESS
POPULATION.
ULTIMATELY, HOWEVER, EVEN
THE GENEROSITY OF A PLACE
LIKE EUGENE HAS LIMITS.
ON THE NIGHT WE ARRIVED
MULTIPLE PEOPLE LIVING IN
THIS MAKESHIFT STRUCTURE.
TWO DAYS LATER THE CITY HAD
CLEARED THE SIDEWALK AND PUT
UP NOTICES IT WAS GOING TO
SCRAP THE BELONGINGS INSIDE.
EUGENE IS TRYING TO GET A
HANDLE ON HOMELESS PROBLEM
BUT THERE ARE ROAD BLOCKS.
A MAJOR ONE, A RULING BY THE
FEDERAL NINTH CIRCUIT OF
APPEALS THAT HAS DECLARED
IT'S SOMEHOW
UNCONSTITUTIONAL TO SHOE
AWAY HOMELESS PEOPLE IF
THERE IS NO PLACE FOR THEM
TO GO.
EUGENE'S LEADERS HAVE
RESPONDED BY TRYING TO ERECT
TENT CITIES ON PUBLIC LAND.
ONE PROPOSAL ENVISIONED
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENT PARKING
LOT AT THE CENTER OF
DOWNTOWN.
SO FAR THOSE EFFORTS HAVE
FAILED.
A LOCAL CHARITY CALLED SAINT
VINCENT DEPAUL HAS STEPPED
IN WITH OWN SOLUTION.
>> THIS IS A MASH TENT.
A STRUCTURE THAT WAS USED BY
THE MILITARY IN SOME OF OUR
FOREIGN DEPLOYMENTS.
>> Tucker: OTHER CITIES ON
THE WEST CODE HAVE TRIED TO
PROVIDE HOUSING FOR THE
HOMELESS.
USUALLY AT REMARKABLE
COMPENSATION.
SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA, FOR
EXAMPLE, IS SPENDING
$37 MILLION ON A BUILDING
THAT WILL HOUSE JUST 83
PEOPLE.
BY CONTRAST, SAINT VINCENT
DEPAUL'S ANSWER IS SIMPLE
AND CHEAP.
>> WE PUT THIS WHOLE SECTION
OF TENTS UP WITH A WORK CREW
IN ONE DAY.
>> Tucker: RESIDENTS ARE
ASSIGNED A BED AND GIVEN A
PLACE TO STORE THEIR
BELONGINGS.
THEY ARE EXPECTED TO MAKE
THEIR BEDS EVERY DAY TO
INSTILL A SENSE OF PRIDE AND
SELF-WORTH.
THE SHELTER IS OPEN TO
ANYONE, INCLUDING DRUNKS AND
DRUG USERS.
THOSE WHO STAY GET TREATED
FOR ADDICTION.
THE STRATEGY ESSENTIALLY IS
THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT CITIES
LIKE SEATTLE AND SAN
FRANCISCO ARE DOING.
SAINT VINCENT DEPAUL'S GOAL
IS TO GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS AND INTO AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY MIGHT
ACTUALLY RECOVER.
OF THE HOUSING ISN'T MEANT
TO BE PERMANENT.
SAINT VINCENT DEPAUL TRIES
TO GET RESIDENTS CLEANED UP
AND READY FOR LONG-TERM
HOUSING IN JUST A FEW
MONTHS.
FOR MANY THE STRATEGY
APPEARS TO BE WORKING.
>> WHAT ARE THE ODDS THAT IN
TWO YEARS THEY ARE BACK ON
THE STREETS?
>> IF THEY STAY IN PROGRAMS
AND IN ASSOCIATION WITH
PEOPLE THAT ARE CLEAN AND
SOBER, CHANCES ARE PRETTY
GOOD THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
STAY OUT.
>> Tucker: WELL THE HOMELESS
CRISIS APPEARS TO BE GETTING
WORSE PRETTY MUCH EVERYWHERE
IN AMERICA RATHER THAN TRY
TO FIX THE PROBLEM THOUGH
ELITES PREFER TO ATTACK ITS
VICTIMS.
IN THE CITY OF SEATTLE, ONE
OF THE PLACES HIT HARDEST BY
THIS CRISIS, A WOMAN HAS
FACED, BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
BACKLASH FOR SEEKING JUSTICE
AFTER SHE SAYS SHE WAS RAPED
BY A HOMELESS MAN WITH
MULTIPLE ARREST WARRANTS.
WE WILL INTERVIEW A
DOCUMENTARY FILMMAKER WHO